If you want to hear about the hidden text
on the computer screens and fourteen never
before revealed Things You Missed in Glass,
then stick around to the end of this video.
The first scene shows the birth of Elijah
Price, and we first see the child who would
later become known as Mr. Glass, through the
reflection of a glass mirror.
This is a common theme in Unbreakable, we’re
introduced to age 13 Elijah through the reflection
of the Glass television screen, and we’re
introduced to Adult Elijah through the reflection
of the glass in one of the pieces at his art
gallery.
When David meets Elijah for the first time,
not only are looking through a glass window,
but the characters are framed in a box, just
like a comic book.
"Here by appointment only."
"I got a card from this store."
The reason for these choices is that Elijah
sees himself as nothing more than a fragile,
broken piece of Glass, and his entire purpose
throughout the film is to find his real place
in the world, and discover why he is the way
he is.
In the next scene we’re introduced to the
protagonist, David Dunn.
Note the alliteration of his name like many
other superheroes: Clark Kent, Peter Parker,
Bruce Banner and several others.
One of the first moments of David being on
screen has him looking at a child in the seat
in front of him, who is upside-down.
Like the recurrent theme of glass, inversion
is also something that’s seen time and time
again in Unbreakable, and to understand it,
it’s important to understand the connection
between the film’s two central characters.
David and Elijah are opposites in every way
but one.
One is invincible, and the other of as fragile
as they come.
One gets sick very easily, the other is never
sick.
One is physically gifted, the other has a
hard time even getting around.
David is light skinned, Elijah has dark skin.
David is very reserved, while Elijah is quite
outgoing.
And of course, David is the hero, while Elijah
is the villain.
So when all is right with the world, the camera
is upright, as it should be.
But when disaster is about to strike… when
something bad is about to happen, the camera
is inverted in relation to its subject, the
upside down girl precedes the train crash,
David’s son Joseph watches TV upside-down
before learning of the crash, Elijah lays
eyes on the comic book that first gives him
the idea that he’s a supposed to be a supervillain
and it’s upside-down, Elijah falls down
the stairs and sees the man with the gun get
away with an inverted perspective and Joseph
sees his dad lift an impossible amount of
weight from upside-down which later leads
him to pull a gun on his father.
There’s also an inversion reference hidden
in the credits.
David’s wife is named Audrey Dunn, but there’s
a separate credit for the actress who played
the age 20 Audrey before her and David were
married, where she’s referred to as Audrey
Inverso.
Finally, Elijah discovers a comic that helps
him find out what David’s kryptonite is
and that’s upside down as well.
Speaking of that kryptonite, that one weakness
that David has, David tells Kelly, the woman
on the train, that he’s thinking about getting
into male synchronised swimming, which is
funny because we later find that his weakness
is water.
Director M Night Shyamalan also used the idea
of water as a weakness in his next film, Signs.
There’s also a connection to his previous
film, The Sixth Sense, in that Bruce Willis
is the star of both movies.
David’s wife also mentions that her favorite
song is Soft and Wet by the artist formerly
known as Prince.
Another word for soft is weak, and David becomes
weaker whenever he gets wet.
Kelly also asks David if he likes football,
and he says, “not really”.
We later find out this is a lie, David was
a huge football star, and he still works as
a security guard at his former school’s
stadium so that he can continue to be around
the game.
Kelly is going to Philadelphia to meet with
a cornerback from Temple University, who later
appears in the movie, he’s in the park playing
football with a bunch of kids, one of which
is David’s son.
Alright...
Always good to be back.
Now where were we?
After the accident, Joseph is seen watching
television.
I don't know how close they're gonna be able
to get David.
These are woods and trees.
It's gonna be a very difficult rescue..."
It starts with this Dole commercial featuring
a skateboarding Banana, then he flips the
channel to Jerry Springer, then the Powerpuff
Girls, which is a 90s superhero cartoon, and
then an episode of I Am Weasel, another 90s
cartoon, this episode is about a smart banana
that comes to life, it’s actually a really
funny episode.
I’m not entirely sure why there are two
separate references to a living, sentient
banana, perhaps an early foreshadowing of
The Horde, whose defining color is yellow.
Or perhaps something with Banana Split?
Could be something there.
I should also probably explain the color scheme
for anyone who hasn’t seen my Glass trailer
analysis.
David is almost always wearing Green, from
his shirt in scene two to his iconic rain
poncho.
Elijah can mostly be found wearing purple
and the present from his mother is wrapped
in purple.
It even goes right down to Elijah’s purple
walled office and David’s kitchen with the
green cabinets, which looks beautiful when
complimented by the orange accents after David
defeats the Orange man… oh man we could
talk about color theory all day with this
movie, but let’s switch back to wherever
we were.
Right.
The TV.
The news of the train wreck comes in on channel
4 news, whose logo resembles the logo of the
Marvel superhero group, the Fantastic Four.
So David ends up being the only survivor of
the train crash , and after the memorial,
receives a note from Elijah, which leads him
to discover he’s never actually been sick.
Then we get the previously mentioned flashback
to Elijah’s childhood where he receives
the gift from his mother, a comic book titled
The Battle With Jaguaro.
Jaguaro is a beast like antagonist wearing
yellow and a reference to The Beast from Split.
Jaguaro is going up against a superhero wearing
green, obviously a reference to David.
“They say this one has a surprise ending.”
Yes, it does.
Elijah tries to sell the original artwork
as an adult, calling it a classic depiction
of good vs. evil.
However, when he learns that the buyer wants
to get this as a present for his kid, Elijah
is outraged.
I love that little moment where Elijah is
explaining that this is an art gallery, not
a toy store, and he asks the prospective buyer,
do you see any Teletubbies in here?
And the guy actually looks, like “oh my
God, there’s no teletubbies in here!”
But anyway, after David meets Elijah, and
thinks he’s a scam artist, which is interesting
in itself considering David’s innate ability
to sense evil, David goes home and reads the
newspaper article about the train crash of
Eastrail 177.
The photo of the wreck is credited to Kevin
Ladson, who’s actually the prop master for
the movie.
In the article, the name of the transportation
secretary is Kia Dickerson, who is also on
the art department of Unbreakable.
Part of the article mentions that the trains
had just had an engine check prior to leaving
the station, an early hint that foul play
was involved.
On the right column, there’s an article
about raising money to build prisons
FOR YOU AND ME TO LIVE IN
Excuse me, to house the number of inmates
expected in the next decade, perhaps some
of the criminals caught by David Dunn will
inhabit these prisons.
Then David takes a look back at the newspaper
highlights from his football career.
One of the articles is written by Scott Murphy,
Shyamalan’s assistant art director, and
the photographer Jim Feng is a reference to
James Feng, another assistant art director.
Here’s another reason I love this movie,
always good to see the Brewers losing.
The article about David’s car crash in college
is written by Robert Holtzman, yet another
assistant set decorator.
He’s interrupted from reliving his glory
days when his wife comes knocking on his door
asking if David has been with anyone since
they started having problems.
“I’m prepared for any answer.
It won’t affect me.”
She’s lying.
“The answer won’t affect me.”
"It won’t affect me either way.”
She’s lying.
“No.”
Told you.
The next day at work, Elijah shows up and
we’re introduced to David’s ability to
sense bad people in a crowd, when he predicts
that a man wearing camouflage is carrying
a silver weapon with a black grip and that
will step out of line, which he does.
Elijah sets out to see if David’s prediction
is correct.
He steps out of his car which is completely
covered in padding, in order to pursue the
guy, but on the stairs to the subway, has
a bad fall, and the shattering of his glass
cane represents his frailty.
I already talked about these scenes, so let’s
move onto the next stadium scene.
A single mother in red bumps into him and
he heads the sounds of child abuse.
Roll it like the spirit of Philadelphia.
“No….”
Maybe… just maybe… this kid is a young
Kevin Wendell Crumb from Split, but it might
be impossible to know for sure.
It is a different actress playing the Mom,
but it has been 15 years, so it's just possible
that they weren't able to get that woman who
was an extra on set back to play the Mom.I
don't know.
Let me know what your thoughts on that are
in the comments though.
Then there’s a cameo from the director M
Night Shyamalan himself.
David is called away from work because his
son Joseph has an injury at school, when he
gets in a fight with two kids, who we later
find out are Potter and some other guy.
“It was Potter and another guy.
There were messing with this Chinese girl
in the dressing room.”
You may remember Potter is the cousin of the
Cornerback from temple.
“He’s Potter’s cousin.
He’s starting cornerback at Temple University.”
Then we’ve got Joseph’s gun scene.
Now supposedly this was inspired by an incident
that really happened to Superman actor George
Reeves, where a child confronted him with
a gun and asked to shoot him to prove Superman
was invincible, and Reeves convinced him to
put the gun down by telling him that someone
might be injured by the ricochet.
I don’t know if that story is true, but
either way it could have been used as inspiration
for the Unbreakable scene.
Finally, David revisits the wrecked train
cars and remembers the incident he and Audrey
went through in college, where we has actually
completely unharmed in the car accident.
He decides to become a vigilante, and saves
the two kids from the orange man.
In the newspaper article that comes out the
next day we find out that those kids were
tied up like that for 3 days.
The author of the article, Nicole Marsella,
is of course an Art Department assistant.
Scott Murphy, the sportswriter from before
also has something to say about the breaking
up of farmland in this other article, so this
man has many passions it seems, and the farmland
stuff could be another hint towards signs
being Shyamalan’s next film.
Finally, David visits Elijah’s art gallery
showing and meets his mother.
“See the villains eyes?
They’re larger than the other characters.
They insinuate a slightly skewed perspective
of how they see the world.”
These are just a couple final clues towards
the reveal that’s about to happen in a couple
minutes.
Elijah has always seen the world from a skewed
perspective through those big eyes of his.
But what’s truly amazing is her next comment.
“But he says there’s always two kinds.
There’s the soldier villain who fights the
hero with his hands… and then there’s
the real threat, the brilliant and evil arch-enemy…
who fights the hero with his mind.”
Shyamalan was planning to bring The Horde
from Split into the equation from the very
beginning.
In fact, he would later reveal that The Horde
was at one point supposed to be a part of
Unbreakable, but he cut the character and
saved him for Split because the movie was
getting too crowded.
The final freeze frame of the movie states
Elijah Price is in an institution for the
criminally insane.
Why would is say that if this is not a true
story, and Shyamalan wasn’t planning on
having Glass take place in that institution
19 years later?
Both Split and Unbreakable open with a birthday
scene.
In Unbreakable, it was the birth of Elijah
Price, and in Split, Claire Benoit celebrates
her birthday.
At the end of the party, her dad offers a
ride to her classmate, Casey Cooke, but he
never quite makes it into the car.
Last week, I described how David Dunn and
Elijah Price are color coded, with David being
associated with green and Elijah being purple.
The Horde has their own color too -- yellow.
It can be seen in Dennis’s handkerchief,
Hedwig's jacket, the flowers placed around
the holding room and at the train station,
the lighting and wall colors throughout the
area below maintenance as well as the tiles
above ground at the zoo.
In the poster for Glass, the colors of each
character are made clear.
There are 24 sets of titles in the opening
and closing credits of Split, one for each
of the 24 identities of The Horde.
The opening credits also have letters connected
by a vertical line in a way that makes it
look like two entries on a timeline, just
as this is the second entry in this series.
The accompanying music by West Dylan Thordson
sounds like distorted animal cries.
Take a listen.
So the girls are kidnapped and put in this
holding room.
Claire and Marcia have different ideas about
how to get out than Casey, and the room is
vertically split, just like the title of the
movie, by this power line to show the divide.
Vertical divisions of the frame are also a
technique used a lot in Alfred Hitchcock’s
horror classic, Psycho.
M Night Shyamalan, the director of Split,
lists Hitchcock as a huge influence, he even
released a 10 minute video on his appreciation
of Hitchcock’s Strangers on a Train.
There are other Psycho references in Split,
but we’ll get to them when we get to them.
Casey tells Marcia to pee herself when Dennis
takes her out of the room -- hoping to prevent
Dennis from forcing her to do something she
doesn’t want to do.
The fact that Dennis is a germaphobe works
in her favor, but really, that was really
just luck.
Around this time, one of the other identities,
Barry, reaches out to their psychologist,
Dr. Fletcher.
She’s got several other emails on the screen.
Just as the art department of Unbreakable
had cameos in the newspaper, the crew of Split
makes cameos in Dr. Fletcher’s email.
Charles S Rowe is credited as a miscellaneous
crew member.
John B West, Dominic Catanzarite and John
Rusk were part of the production department.
Mitch Campbell, Lucas Andrei, Jennifer Wessner,
Ed Mendez and Bob Lowery all worked visual
effects.
Skip Lievsay, Bryan Baker, Adam Leach and
Matthew Shapiro were part of the post production
team.
And Lisa Liberati is James McAvoy’s girlfriend.
One of the emails mentions Cezanne, the French
painter, we’ll come back to that later.
I love all these movies with just disturbing
pictures in the background.
Anyway, Barry comes to see Dr. Fletcher, but
it’s not really Barry.
Dr. Fletcher asks if he’s looking for something,
but he’s actually putting the room in order,
because it’s really Dennis, the guy with
OCD.
Imagine having a disorder within your disorder.
Maybe Mr. Glass can relate.
“I have something called osteogenesis imperfecta.
It’s a genetic disorder.”
"My name is Dr. Ellie Staple, and I'm a psychiatrist.
I specialize in those individuals who believe
they are super heroes."
Anyway, the supposed Barry talks about making
a jacket hand printed with newspaper headlines.
“That’s supposed to be like a tailored
jacket, but I’m gonna handprint it with
newspaper headlines.”
I know someone who happens to have a collection
of newspaper headlines.
Also in Dr. Fletcher’s office there’s
a picture on the wall of what appears to be
a woman looking behind a shower curtain. this
is one of those Psycho references I was talking
about.
After Dennis leaves, Dr. Fletcher goes through
her patient files.
The only one that’s legible is this one
on a Mr. Douglass Latreille.
As far as I can tell, the name is not relevant,
but the dates on the file range from July
2000 to November 2000.
November 2000 is when Unbreakable was released,
and most of the movie is set within these
dates, for example the encounter with The
Orange Man in Unbreakable takes place just
before October 23rd 2000.
She also has a bin labeled ‘Universal Offices’.
You can probably guess who produced this movie.
Dr. Fletcher visits an art gallery to view
this Cezanne painting, probably the one she
received the email about.
This piece is called the Bathers.
Would it be too much of a stretch to relate
this to David Dunn’s swimming pool accident
or fear of water?
If your answer is yes, that is too much of
a stretch, then fine, but there’s no denying
this line from Dr. Fletcher’s associate
Joe, was an intentional clue.
“You treat them like they’re supernaturally
gifted, like they have powers or something.
Karen, these are patients.
They have been through trauma.”
Whoa, that’s a good one.
I’m curious if any of you picked up on that
the first time through, and at what point
did you actually realize this was a sequel.
I tried to look for some more clues in Dr.
Fletcher’s notes on the various identities,
but I couldn’t really make out anything.
I don’t know if this is supposed to be a
joke on that whole trope about doctors having
bad handwriting, but I can’t read any of
it, so let’s go back to Casey and the girls.
Casey awakes from a flashback and we see her
point of view which is sideways.
When I talked about Unbreakable, I examined
the right-side-up vs upside-down shots in
that movie, so maybe these sideways shots
in Split are a little bit of an in-between.
This is also one of the first time we get
a good peek out of the holding room and there’s
a container of Barnum Animal Crackers, one
of the earliest clues towards their location
being the Philadelphia Zoo.
“It took forever to get this place safe
without the nosy-bodys who work here finding
out.
You can’t get out of here!”
Back at Dr. Fletcher’s office, we’ve got
our M Night cameo in the form of this guy
who helps Dr. Fletcher review security camera
footage of Dennis deliberately trying to prove
that he’s Barry by walking through the trash.
When Patricia brings Casey and Marcia into
the kitchen, you can briefly see that they
all have different cereal preferences, which
I found to be an interesting detail.
One of the things I talked about in Unbreakable
is how we always see Elijah through a glass
reflection to represent the fragile nature
of his disorder.
We see Elijah though the a reflection each
time he is introduced at a new age.
In Split, we see Dennis in the reflection
of this certificate just before he first introduces
himself to Dr. Fletcher.
There’s another reflection scene later on,
which I’ll come back to.
But in this conversation, we find out that
the 24th identity, The Beast, resides away
from the other 23 identities in a train yard,
because Kevin’s dad left on a train when
he was young, presumably, that was Eastrail
177.
Casey convinces Hedwig to show her his room,
which, in another clue about them being under
the zoo, is filled with animal posters and
toys.
Additionally the song that he famously dances
to in his room is called “Frogbass” by
the artist currently known as Snails.
And this is actually a pretty good drawing
of Reshiram if that’s what it’s supposed
to be.
Hedwig shows Casey the walkie talkie that
he stole from Dennis, and Casey uses it to
try to call help, but the man on the other
end thinks that it’s just his friend pulling
his leg and assures him he still has the orange
headphones.
When Casey eventually does get out at the
end of the movie, we do see him listening
to the orange headphones before he calls the
police.
But, before any of that, there’s a very
important flashback where young Casey holds
her abusive Uncle at gunpoint, in a scene
that’s very, very reminiscent of Joseph
holding David at gunpoint in Unbreakable.
Roll it.
Split: “This isn’t funny.”
Unbreakable: “Joseph what the hell are you
doing?”
Split: “Is it loaded?”
Unbreakable: “Joseph did you load that gun?”
Split: “Casey”
Unbreakable: “Joseph.”
Split: “I’m your Uncle.”
Unbreakable: “Now I am your father…”
Split: “Stop it Casey.”
Unbreakable: “Joseph!”
Split: “Put that gun down.”
Unbreakable: “and I’m telling you to put
that ******* gun down right now!”
Split: “I’m getting upset.
I’m about to get very angry!”
Unbreakable: “You are about to be in big
trouble!”
Split: “You could have killed me.”
These scenes take place at almost the exact
same point in both movies.
Maybe one day I’ll do a side by side comparison,
but that sounds like another video.
Dr. Fletcher’s concern leads her to try
to talk to The Horde at his home, so she pull
up in a taxi.
Remember how the Channel 4 news logo in Unbreakable
was very reminiscent of the Fantastic Four
logo?
Well the letter T in this taxi cab service
is also a reference to the Teen Titans logo.
The pieces are all coming together as Dennis
visits the train station to transform into
The Beast, and it’s an Amtrak train just
like Eastrail 177.
Casey explores The Horde’s computer, and
this is where we see video diaries of each
member.
One of them is named Norma, which completes
the trifecta of Psycho references, this one
referencing Norma Bates.
At some point, Dr. Fletcher realizes she probably
won’t make it out alive, but she leaves
a note for the captive girls to find.
The note is written on a receipt from “Hagenbaugh
Laboratories”.
Which is not a thing.
BUT, Emily Hagenbaugh is the author of this
superhero book.
So you know how the rest goes, Casey has her
confrontation with the Beast, the Beast sees
that she too has gone through abuse and lets
her live.
Someone finds her and escorts her from the
below maintenance area and the orange headphones
guy calls the police.
One of the most disturbing things to me, is
that even after all that Casey has been through,
she still doesn’t want to go back with her
Uncle at the end.
That’s how bad he is.
But there’s one more loose end that still
hasn’t been tied up.
On my end.
I mentioned the Unbreakable reference where
we see The Horde in the reflection in Dr.
Fletcher’s office, just like those Elijah
Price scenes from the first movie.
The final scene with The Horde goes all in
on this, and includes the panning back and
forth camera movement, as seen in many of
the scenes of Unbreakable.
All the while James Newton Howard’s Unbreakable
soundtrack slowly transitions in as we cut
to the credits and the iconic in-credit scene
and the reveal of David Dunn.
I’ve got goosebumps just thinking about
it.
Now the stage is set for Glass and I could
not be more excited.
Glass begins with four cheerleaders abducted
by Hedwig and David Dunn, who is starting
to become known as the Overseer, shifting
his focus from petty criminals to The Horde.
We first see him take out these kids who are
filming themselves Superman punching a random
guy on the street to try to go viral.
These low criminals are pretending to be superheroes
online, which provides a stark contrast with
the ending of Glass where real superheroes
leak on social media.
When David first enters the house, he runs
water from a faucet, a strange choice considering
water is his only weakness.
"Who's there?"
David now has his own security company, Dunn
Home Security.
Elijah says in Unbreakable says that David
works in security for a reason, because he’s
a born protector, so it makes sense that he
gets his own company.
“You could have been a tax accountant.
You could have owned your own gym.
You could have opened a chain of restaurants.
You could have done one of 10,000 things,
but in the end you chose to protect people.
You made that decision, and I find that very,
very interesting.”
Joseph keeps a list of quotes said by the
criminals David has taken out.
At the bottom of the notebook, one says “Get
ready to get on the pain train.”
David first discovers his powers by surviving
a train wreck.
The one Joseph writes down about how he’s
gonna salt bae him, is a reference to this
meme.
If anyone was wondering, these Twitter accounts
look like they were created for the movie,
then, stripped of all their content, or possibly
created after the fact to prevent anyone from
pretending to be associated with the movie.
The Reddit page that Joseph finds the Overseer
article on also has a link at the bottom reading:
“We dead yet?”
That may be a clue about the ending of the
movie.
The Philly Crime Time website doesn’t actually
exist, in fact, there’s not even a .com
in this URL.
One of the suggested articles on the side
says: “Local citizen sees and stops assault,
says Tiptoe Man inspired him to act.
And then in the Four More Teens Abducted article,
it says, “some legal experts are even arguing
that one personality can not be held accountable
for the actions of another, hinting at many
legal obstacles ahead if the man is ever apprehended.
The next day at work, M Night Shyamalan, the
director of the trilogy, makes his cameo appearance,
and it answers one of the questions I had
going into the movie.
He mentions that he’s getting more cameras
because one of his tenants was killed off-site.
He’s talking about Dr. Fletcher, so it seems
that Jai, from Split wasn’t just an IT guy
helping Dr. Fletcher review security footage,
but actually her landlord.
And probably also her landlord.
“You can’t use your thumbs to spin the
wheel dumb--.”
Jai goes on to see David and he recognises
him as the security guard from those years
ago, and tells him he used to hang out with
the shady types at the stadium, but he turned
his life around.
This confirms that Stadium Drug Dealer and
Jai are in fact the same character, but this
is more than just a fun little director’s
cameo, it shows the effect that David had
cleaning up the crime around his city; he
actually had a positive impact on the community
and helped turn shady people into functioning
members of society.
David goes out again to look for The Horde
with Joseph giving him tips via headphones
and GPS tracker.
Not only is this a common superhero trope,
but it’s also a concept that Shyamalan used
in his 2013 film After Earth, although in
that movie, the roles were reversed and it
was the father giving advice to his son.
After David bumps into Hedwig on the street,
he heads toward the brick factory to look
for the girls, and the word Allies is written
in graffiti on a window in the background,
a foreshadowing the teaming up of Elijah and
The Horde.
“That sounds like the bad guys teaming up.
“
The comic that Dr. Staple is looking at during
the final visit to the shop at the end is
also called Supervillain team up.
There are also huge letters spelling END,
possibly because of the twist endings to each
movie.
I also saw it says bender, which reminded
me of that Futurama episode where Bender and
Flexo get a job in a factory.
When David is first taken into Raven Hill
Memorial, the text on the top right corner
of the security camera view says H20 because
David’s weakness is water and he’s about
to be surrounded by it.
In the Unbreakable Things You Missed, I discussed
how upside-down camera composition was used
to foreshadow bad things happening, and the
trend seems to continue in Glass.
When David first has the confrontation with
The Beast, we see the Beast’s point of view
as he crawls along the ceiling towards David
and the rescued cheerleaders.
Like many supervillains, The Beast has a signature
move, which is, fittingly, a giant bear hug.
This is the same attack he used on Dr. Fletcher
during Split, on David during the factory
fight and the orderly when he and Mr. Glass
are escaping.
Throughout the series, broken glass is used
as a metaphor of the well being of the characters,
so when David and The Beast’s battle sends
them out of the factory through a shattering
glass window it spells the beginning of the
end for them, because it leads to their capture
and placement in Raven Hill Memorial.
Once we arrive at that institution, there
is huge clue about the final twist of the
movie.
As they are placed in their rooms, we are
shown the point of view of the cameras placed
around the institution.
The entire movie, these security camera shots
are constantly being shown, the final twist
is dangled in front of us all along.
The characters are introduced to their new
psychiatrist, Dr. Ellie Staple.
At the end of the movie, we find out that
Dr. Staple is part of the ancient organization
created to suppress superheroes from the public.
When that happens, she tells Mr. Glass that
she they don’t take sides, she’s not good
or evil, she essentially falls in the middle.
In a literal comic book there are staples
placed in the middle crease to hold everything
together.
Her name represents her neutrality.
The secret organisation is also something
Mr. Glass knows about way back in Unbreakable.
"That's why this group, the coalition of evil,
tried to ascertain the weakness of every superhero
because they all have one."
They got it wrong in the comics.
They talk about secret evil groups trying
to stop the heroes.
I don't think we are particularly evil, and
we don't choose sides.
Casey gets word of The Beast’s capture when
she’s pulled aside at school, and we also
see that she attended the same school as Joseph
Dunn.
I’m honestly not entirely sure what the
point of that was outside of furthering the
idea that everything is connected in a comic
book story, much like how David and Clarence
W Crumb were on the same train.
Which, as a quick side note, Clarence’s
name continues the theme of alliteration in
the first two movies with characters like
David Dunn, Casey Cooke, Kevin Crumb, and
now Clarence Crumb.
There’s also a character that I noticed
in the IMDb credits called Scarlet Shields…
I honestly have no idea who that even is.
I’m assuming she’s a minor character,
but basically every other minor character
has a name like Hospital Patient or Cheerleading
Girl #4.
I honestly have no idea who this is supposed
to be.
Maybe she was given a name just to throw off
people trying to look up information online
before the movie came out?
David’s son Joseph meets with Dr. Staple
to try to convince her to let David go free.
When he is unsuccessful, the camera tilts
down into an upside-down position again to
watch Joseph leave the facility.
Just as Joseph saw the original train crash
footage upside-down on the couch in Unbreakable,
this camera movement in Glass also represents
impending disaster.
Speaking of Unbreakable, when I saw the scene
of David coming into a young Joseph’s room,
I was completely blown away by it, because
somehow I had no idea that these deleted scenes
from the first film existed, and this one
really works well considering the themes of
Glass.
Let’s roll it.
“I’m not scared.”
“That’s great.”
“You know why?
I know now.”
“Know what?”
“Your secret identity.”
So Joseph felt uneasy about the fact that
his father has these incredible abilities
that can’t be explained, but finds comfort
in knowing he has someone to protect him.
This helps explain why it was so important
for Mr. Glass to outsmart the black clover
society and broadcast the existence of superheroes
out to the world.
Next, Casey is given the opportunity to meet
with The Horde, and discovers that her touch
can bring Kevin forward into the light.
My theory as to why Casey has this ability
relates to the fact that the additional identities
were created by Kevin’s brain as a coping
mechanism for the abuse dished out by his
mother.
It’s stated in Split that the Horde exists
to protect Kevin,
“Are you in charge?”
“Yeah, we’ve taken charge.
We’re the only ones that can protect Kevin.”
“We’re all here to protect Kevin.”
“He’s very weak.”
So naturally, the way to bring down these
protections is with love and kindness.
Casey is the only one who’s capable of this
because she too has been abused by her Uncle,
so she knows what kind of gentle hand is needed
to undo the damage.
When Casey leaves the institution after that,
she puts on the jacket given to her by the
man working at the Philadelphia Zoo who escorts
her out of danger at the end of Split.
My guess is that she still wears that jacket
as a reminder of how she stood up to The Beast
-- something that also gave her the strength
to stand up to her Uncle, and just to be a
stronger, braver person overall.
In the final examination scene, Dr. Staple
tries to convince Mr. Glass, The Horde and
The Overseer that they don’t actually have
super powers by giving rational explanations
for everything that has happened and telling
them they will remain institutionalized for
the rest of their lives if they are unable
to overcome their “disorder”.
In a way, she is actually telling the truth
-- although we don’t know it yet, the black
clover society was planning to kill them if
Dr. Staple didn’t successfully convince
them they are ordinary in the three day timespan.
But I’ll get back to the black clover society
later in this video.
Dr. Staple tells David he has symptoms of
the supposed superhero disorder, but lacks
some kind of anchoring incident that made
him realize that he is a superhero, which
is funny because the “anchoring incident”
he thinks of is literally him drowning like
an anchor.
One of the main talking points that Dr. Staple
uses to try to convince them that they are
ordinary, is that if superheroes do exist,
why would there only be the three of them?
This is Dr. Staple counting on the fact that
her black clover society will always be successful
in suppressing any supers from the public
eye.
David and Patricia appear to have their faith
in their own powers shaken.
Elijah, doesn’t respond, because he’s
pretending to be a vegetable, but he knows
that Dr. Staple is lying to them.
All the talk of comic books sends Casey to
the comic-book store to do some of her own
research, and the store is owned by none other
than the comic book store clerk from Unbreakable.
It seems that his suspicions of pervs in back
of the store hasn’t changed either, when
he yells to Joseph, “you better not be one
of those Hello Kitty pervs.”
“You better not be jacking off to the Japanese
comics I swear to God.”
In the background there’s a comic titled
"Strange Happenings" which is possibly a nod
to M. Night's 2008 film "The Happening", and
as Joseph leaves the store, he notices a comic
book called "Whisperman", which has been made
specifically for this movie.
The artist has a YouTube Channel, where he
calls the character a puppet-master of sorts,
which reminds me of Dr Staple’s attempt
to manipulate the heroes into thinking they’re
ordinary.
Shortly after, he does some research on Kevin
Crumb, and the author of one of the articles
is Matthew Shapiro, one of the guys who emailed
Dr. Fletcher in Split.
When Mr. Glass looks at Kevin’s file, if
you pause you can discover that Kevin’s
mother also had DID.
It says “Mother unfit for child custody.
Mother’s mental illness (DID) may have a
profound effect on her child’s development,
including an increased risk of the child developing
the same disorder.”
So when his father was on Eastrail 177, he
was seeking help for his wife at the time,
not his son.
Just as the mirror reflection shots are used
to introduce villains in Unbreakable and Split,
similar shots are used in Glass to show that
something is not right.
David sits on floor of his cell and his reflection
is distorted by the curved wall.
It is shortly after this that we discover
Elijah was faking his sedation and has the
ability to sneak out of his room and he discovers
the magazine advertising the opening of Osaka
Tower.
Just as the previous movies had subtle references
to The Fantastic Four and Teen Titans, the
headline of this article calls Osaka Tower
a true MARVEL.
Also, in a look-in at the Osaka Tower article
I saw the photography was done by Dave Kellom,
an art department coordinator on Glass.
Elijah tells The Beast that his plan is to
attack the tower on its opening date, December
7th, which is Pearl Harbor Day another major
American disaster.
More importantly, that’s also my birthday,
so put that down in your calendar right now.
Right now.
Then we get a glimpse into Elijah’s past,
when he sneaks onto a carnival ride and tries
to protect himself using stuffed animals.
This is another deleted scene, but again,
it works really well here because The Beast
ends protecting him from the orderlies and
the police as they break out of the hospital,
so it’s kind of as if he’s been protected
by animals every step of the way.
It’s also interesting to note that his plan
on the carnival ride backfires, and he ends
up breaking his shoulder, just as The Beast
turns on him at the end of Glass and breaks
his shoulder, an injury he would never overcome.
After Elijah discovers the powers of The Beast,
he formulates his plan to have The Beast battle
David in front of the world.
I think it’s important to note that it was
never Mr. Glass’s real intention to go to
the tower, all he really needed to do was
convince The Beast to break them out so he
could stream it using the cameras.
And for anyone who felt that David Dunn’s
part in all of this was a little underwhelming,
let’s not forget that it was most likely
Dunn’s security company who provides all
the cameras to the institution in the first
place.
Part of Elijah’s plan was to change out
the lens of the machine used for his surgery,
then get himself caught lollygagging around
on camera so that the doctor moves up the
date of his operation.
This is important because it allows the orderly,
Daryl, to let his guard down around Elijah,
giving him the opportunity to slit his throat
with the broken shard of glass.
And just as Elijah’s broken glass cane represented
his injuries in Unbreakable, the broken picture
frames foreshadow his eventual demise in Glass.
All three characters have their “broken
glass moment”.
At the end of the second act there are a couple
more clever uses of shots that use mirror
reflections to tell us something.
The first is Dr. Staple getting out of her
car and heading into Raven Hill Memorial,
which we see through her side mirror.
These mirrors always come with a disclaimer:
objects in mirror are closer than they appear.
Well, Dr. Staple is not just a psychiatrist
as she appears to be, because she’s actually
part of this secret organization.
Our earlier mirror shots of David and The
Horde are distorted by curved mirrors, but
when Elijah finally meets The Beast, he first
sees the transformation through the reflection
of a glass cabinet.
And there’s no distortion here, which tells
us that things are going to be essentially
as they should be with the impending clash
of good vs. evil.
When Dr. Staple realizes that Elijah has broken
out, she sees the news report on TV about
the opening of Osaka Tower, and thinks Mr.
Glass is going to sabotage it.
Also, the reporter is the same guy who reports
on the missing girls in Split, and on the
news ticker at the bottom, there is a report
about cryptocurrency.
Krypton is the name of Superman’s home planet,
and Superman is referenced several times throughout
Glass.
Shortly after, the final battle begins, and
Dr. Staple curiously tells someone to make
sure to keep patients and staff away from
the south side windows.
This is because she knows that David, Elijah
and Kevin’s powers are real, and it’s
her duty to make sure nobody finds out about
them.
So that brings us back to this whole black
clover society.
Who are they?
Where did they come from?
Why do they have these matching tattoos?
And what do they have to do with Split and
Unbreakable?
The answers to all of these questions are
coming up.
At the end of the confrontation, a mysterious
group of SWAT members all sharing a wrist
tattoo of black three leaf clover show up
to kill David and The Beast.
Dr. Staple is revealed to be a part of this
society.
She explains that they are a group that has
been around for 10,000 years to keep superheroes
out of the public eye, because it’s not
fair to the rest of society to have Gods walking
among us.
Dr. Staple’s mission the entire time was
to get them to believe that their powers weren’t
real so they can go on living ordinary lives.
She was given the three days to do so, but
if she failed, the alternative was some kind
of brain surgery, or death.
In Split, we are shown how the organization’s
manipulation of society has worked.
Society sees The Horde’s dissociative identity
disorder as a problem, a mental illness that
needs to be cured.
Dr. Fletcher’s thesis to the medical community
is that maybe those with this condition are
actually extraordinarily gifted.
“Well, we look at people who are shattered
and different as less than.
But what if they are more than us?”
But Dr. Fletcher is largely rejected by her
peers, and it’s because the black clover
society has been working for 10,000 years
to condition us to see this as a mental illness.
That’s exactly what Dr. Staple does in Glass,
she rounds up three of the most extraordinary
supers in Philadelphia and tries to convince
them that something is wrong with them and
that they need treatment.
That’s why she wants Casey to get Kevin
to hold onto the light, because she is aware
of the power someone with DID is capable of.
The existence of this group also explains
a question brought up way back when Elijah
and David have their first meeting in Unbreakable.
“I believe comics are our last link to an
ancient way of passing on history.
The Egyptians drew on walls.
Countries all over the world still pass on
knowledge through pictorial forms.”
Remember when Dr. Staple is meeting with Joseph,
Casey and Elijah’s mother, and tries to
convince them that comics are nothing more
than fantasy?
She even brings up comic-book conventions
to try to invalidate them.
The only time she gets frustrated is when
they try to link their situation to what they
have seen in comic books.
The clover society is there to ensure that
these stories exist through pictures, as seemingly
fictional stories, but nothing more.
“I believe comics are a form of history
that someone somewhere felt or experienced.
Then of course those experiences and that
history got chewed up in the commercial machine,
got jazzed up, made into titillating cartoons
for the sale rack.”
In Glass, the “someone somewhere” Elijah
is referring to is his mother, Joseph and
Casey, only this time instead of distributing
comics to be chewed up in the commercial machine,
they have actual video evidence of the existence
of these powers.
Dr. Staple also mentions that when one super
appears, another is likely to appear opposite
of him, and it just leads to conflict, which
is why she feels the clover society needs
to appear to pacify them.
“If there is someone like me in the world
and I am at one end of the spectrum, couldn’t
there be someone else opposite of me at the
other end.
Someone who doesn’t get sick, who doesn’t
get hurt like the rest of us.
And he probably doesn’t even know it.”
OK, but why the black clover tattoos, that
seems kind of random?
Well maybe not.
We can look at it from the secret organization’s
perspective and from a filmmaking perspective.
First from a filmmaking perspective.
The fact that David, Elijah and The Horde’s
journey as superpowered humans ends with a
tattoo of these clovers kind of brings the
trilogy full circle.
Let’s go wayyy back to when we are introduced
to David in Unbreakable.
A woman appears asking him if he’s alone,
and she takes the spot next to him on the
train.
He notices a tattoo on her abdomen which appears
to be a rose, but we only see the bottom of
the stem because this is the very root of
David’s story.
When we see the secret society’s clover
tattoos at the very end of David’s story,
we’re seeing the top of the plant, so it's
as if we’ve come all the way around.
But then why not use a rose tattoo for the
society as well?
The clover does a better job of representing
their values.
They essentially want to purge the world of
anyone who has these rare, special powers.
A four leaf clover is considered a rare and
lucky find, much like how a superhero is a
rare incredible standout in our society.
But the black clover people don’t want that,
they want everyone to be a three leaf clover
and that’s why is was chosen as the symbol
of their organization.
Finally, there was one other minute detail
that I felt really brought the series to a
nice conclusion.
Mr. Glass famously gets his supervillain name
from the kids that made fun of his condition,
osteogenesis imperfecta.
“They called me Mr. Glass.”
Elijah’s mother lives across from a playground,
we see this in a flashback during Unbreakable.
At the end of Glass, before the email comes
in from Elijah containing the footage of the
final battle, you can hear the sounds of children
playing from outside.
How fitting that the very playground with
the kids that poked fun at Elijah, part of
what put the villain idea in his head and
gave him his awakening as a supervillain can
be heard again, just before Elijah’s mother
puts out that video to help all heroes and
villains across the world have their realization
and awakening.
When David first accepts his newfound powers
in Unbreakable, Elijah tells him to go to
where there are people, and he goes to the
train station.
That’s exactly what Mrs. Price, Joseph and
Casey do when they unveil the existence of
these comic book heroes to the world.
This has been the Ultimate Compilation of
Things You Missed in the Eastrail 177 trilogy.
Click the video on the left if you want to
see the Ultimate Compilation of Things You
Missed in IT: Chapter 1.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications, and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.